let's do this okay today okay okay
Arianna yeah Arianna where you from
where I was born in Las Vegas Nevada but
I was raised in South Central LA and
tell me about your family hit both your
parents as a kid I'll mix you kick even
German my mom's side of the family
they're Cubans but they're in Las Vegas
I was raised with my Mexican family
that's why I don't have my accent as
well no I'm Cuban accent my Lavinia is
it hottie sound yeah they have a little
lingo to their were to have a little
salsa in you know in their words but I
didn't grow up with them so I didn't
come out with action the hell was
banished was my first language I learn
English by school oh I see I graduated
high school John C Fremont I went to
college for one semester I took Criminal
Investigation psychology speech a police
organization in swamp ten steps ahead of
the organizations I'm what you call
organized crime they'll take the pretty
face for granted because I'm more than
half of these guys that carry straps and
guns and [ __ ] drugs
so you see youth mistreats me everybody
just reach for seven years give it a
game hmm
these streets made me wait how old are
you 26 I feel 40 I've been living in
these streets for seven years and I'm
tired so easy let me go back to your
childhood how was your childhood it was
pretty gruesome my Grandpere
my grandparents were strict my grandpa
was straight from Mexico he beat me with
everything he fine horsewhips
sandals branches from the tree his shoes
one time I made my cousin eat food dog
food by actually because I thought it
was a Scooby Snack because I watch too
much do we do
he made me eat the dog food and I throw
up all over myself one time I accidently
stepped on my cousin's hanging he made
me put my hand on the floor stepped on
my foot on my head so how do you like
that
he beat me every day I learned by Gabey
he said girls like you need to get
beaten her to you learn so he's from
Mexico so the way he was he taught me is
tie my shoelaces by beating me and if I
didn't get it right the little bunny
ears he would beat me every time smack
me talking
back hands I'm talking slaps in the face
pulling in the hair and a little
technique and he made me kneel on
uncooked rice for 30 minutes in a corner
and that was my crucial punishment
straight from Mexico cold piece of work
bro one time um I said something like
ain't that a piece of [ __ ] that my
grandpa kicked me out Indian accent come
I call him and he said no cuz he found a
condom under my mattress and found out
that I was [ __ ] when I was 18 he said
I thought you was a virgin you're no
longer my grandmother my granddaughter
I lost ownership of you I don't respect
you you're a hoe he said you're all here
18 years old you're [ __ ] you call
yourself a woman cuz you're getting
kicked down at 18 years old you're not
my granddaughter so he kicked me up and
I left when I was 18 I said as soon as
that turn 18 I'm leaving and that's what
I do I've been in the streets ever since
where'd you go to 18 hmm what did you
start doing at 18 prostituting I joined
gangbanging when I was 21 I joined
Florence if there's 13 my dad's from
there my uncles are from there I got
beat with a crowbar one day Watts up
[ __ ] flowers by my enemies for more in
town Watts they want me dead because I
put him in the pin they call me a snitch
I asked my older homies does that make
me a snitch if I put a guy in jail
instead of dirty my hands myself he said
not because he was a man and you didn't
deserve that and he should have had his
homegirls ahead of it so there's a price
on my head I told this guy from watts if
you get a phone call says we want her
dead tie her up till we get there then
we'll take it from there would you do it
they say hell yeah I would cuz you got a
big-ass mouth I'm the type of person
that needs the last word I'll shut up
who people say shut up [ __ ] cuz I'm not
a big chunk out of god-given name and
it's every [ __ ] honor
ariana grande not cuz I think Ariana
like chi-chi's did about you that means
the little one from the hood Julia
Roberts the high cheekbones and smile
huh yeah pretty woman a baby prostitute
that's what I was that's what I became
since I was a little girl oh my god you
look like Julia
I said really that woman who plays a
prostitute that's what I became
I saw the movie once and I got the
message make your money what's in
between is your price position so I made
my money I I met a pimp named a one from
Crips I got my eyes B because um I
messed with a guy from Florence so he
beat me with an extension till I bled
cuz I took my pimp to his house he like
I said he wanted to talk to work and he
heard him saying we're gonna put her
back to work woman gave her this dress
we're gonna beat her up and send her
back on his track soldier hold on
soldier my jets Flores you're 13 km T
watts Shawn he zipped up that's when he
shoots you and have to zip up your
stomach they jumped him up they they
blew him up so hard they had to take
chunks of this dye to put it on his
stomach he was in the hospital with a
tube in his mouth on life support
he barely lived my chance I loved him
but I hate him because he beat me and I
didn't deserve that people take my
kindness for weakness I used to be very
nice but I can't grow splits and cold
peace word and I'm the [ __ ] to the
fullest I am partner than half of these
guys who carry straps and [ __ ]
crystal meth and a pipe I tell you they
gangster nah bro get your eyes B get
mistake for a [ __ ] an informant get
side up get yourself one take it away
and get almost burned with a strainer
because they think you snitched
I said baraja at 13 if I'm a snitch my
own homies would have killed me I said I
got the job off puts me in for me I gave
the cops my number I said think about it
I said well my homies know about this
they said if you don't want to - we
could do it undercover
let us know there's guns in the house
and we'll get you back in I got [ __ ]
hit in the face by a Ty Cobb in house
[ __ ] - you ain't even [ __ ] of the
Dodger Stadium I got hit what a Dodgers
bat in my face by Ty Cobb a nice [ __ ]
named crystal Garcia cuz she still alive
let's rock book you know the [ __ ] was
dead the [ __ ] is dead to me
Larnell she made me homeless again it
took a long time to get back on my feet
I met this white boy named Ikki from
Lawndale [ __ ] lop that's how you did
some call me flower out I'll take his
whole team out that's like Paul Walker
with no teeth slam back on heroin
I said I'll G you know somewhere I could
smoke my pipe get off my feet man and
Gardena cuz I got jumped by the Hoover's
remember me [ __ ] I took a shower a
black member a black gangster from
Hoover's I know what she was my enemy
but I played with fire today she jumped
me later that night with two other black
girls threw me on to bed mattress and
broke cabinets on me I have a bone
sticking up cuz I ended up in the ER
tonight they didn't stop beating me I
was yelling for my life nobody jumped in
same thing with the Warren town cam t
what I was in a dress and chocolates and
I took a paisa to buy some dope but I
took him to my hood that's where I
[ __ ] up cuz my hood my homies don't
even clean me they just said to my dad
he said whatever put my daughter in the
hood better take her eyes off they said
now G shame for another we busted a
train on her to to only three of them
show 50 or more happy show let's [ __ ]
this [ __ ] in the hood I would have been
looser than a goose ah I like a [ __ ]
goose I didn't do it I I condone in it
that happen to me but it didn't my luck
I guess but I didn't get a real
initiation and I beg to the fullest my
dad's been there my uncles are there so
I'm Florence bound regardless if I got a
text or not as small as it is at 13
world's most notorious gang gang last
search of Florence you're through sir
I'm Mexican Cuban and German three races
and I'm crazy people take my pretty
things granted and the streets made me
so like I said as pretty as I am don't
ever cross me cuz if you do I will get
you ten times worse and don't say I
didn't warn people
put me in her car smoke me out and they
[ __ ] me over
tell me get the [ __ ] on in Fontana I had
a black man sit on my chest
put my hand on a Bible when I was turned
up to be with the truth he sat on my
chest said [ __ ] if you don't suck my
dick I'll kill you what a strap on my
head I don't know how I got away but
maybe God left out that time but he got
existed after the [ __ ] I Baker whatever
happened so I became Illuminati I saw my
soul to the devil I'm a devil worshiper
then I prayed to another one called son
time what day it's a grim reaper of the
skeleton bejeweled red eyes like Medusa
she turns into stone not she touches you
you're dead it's a type of devil
worshipping but she's called the saint
of death it's a Mexican theme or the
Salvadorians more of a cartel theme all
you got to do is worship her say a
prayer to light a candle put some things
that are valuable to you like rings
goodies treats in prison is the most
known thing for something worth day
worshiping prison people have her and a
statue she has a Grim Reaper she has the
hoodie
she had bejeweled red eyes like stones
like daisies but they're red but they're
not big easy they're bejeweled red eyes
you look her in the eyes you're dead
all I got to do is make a prayer and
wish she were dead she's gonna get you
won't touch your dick oh please I want
undead and I pray and I'll give her a
good reason why to kill you and your
dead bro it's called playing with
witchcraft
it's called devil worshipping it's
called um witch hunt
it's like when girls put love spells and
guys light a candle let you eat their
[ __ ] let you eat them all when they're
um did you let a guy eat you out when
you're mister period as soon as you
taste your blood it's like a vampire he
falls in love instantly as soon as you
let a guy hit raw you're tight
I'm up at the [ __ ] give you anything
you want drugs takes your shopping gives
your house it's as long as you know
still for me you want something ask for
it but if I buy something in your pocket
Saturday morning so that's where your
backhanding where your ass hoping he's
gonna go
my ex-boyfriend still wears that I
snitched on him when he beat me with an
extension cord the cops wanted me to
testify against court they subpoenaed me
I got the subpoena I looked at it throw
it to the side I didn't show up to court
cuz I was high Oh crystal
methamphetamine that's my choice that's
my drug of choice but I use any drug out
there anything I'd get my hands on PCP
up to the new drug nowadays that's ten
times harder than heroin I overdosed
over once in MacArthur Park know that no
it's called China wipe the street name
blac Chyna
it's a white substance it looks like
crystal and crack cocaine but you could
tell the difference cuz they all have
like a different tone to it and a smell
you're still using today yeah I just
smoked the ball or you and you're five
months pregnant my mom did it why can't
I what makes me a bad person
my baby gonna live [ __ ] or not I'm
gonna love it
my mom [ __ ] me up I came out with
severe depression bipolar schizophrenia
and anxiety I need ten pills to calm me
down but I rather use drugs cuz crystal
meth calms me down
I'm a dope baby crystal meth is in my
body instead of using those ten pills
I sell prescribed with crystal meth I
smoked it a slime and sniff and a turkey
baster turkey bases when they put in
your eyes hold the syringe put a little
bit of water or else he just sharted
but that burns your house like putting a
razor up your ass if it's Cuddy is gonna
burn your [ __ ] I still put vaseline
on me earlier because I put a shard this
[ __ ] big and I didn't think it was
that good my [ __ ] felt like it was on
fire like if I got pepper spray this
[ __ ] ass so you know who the father
of your child is his name
yes I do and you have a relationship
with him as far as we know we're just
having the kid is he one of your
customers huh is he one of your
customers he's just my baby daddy oh I
see
he's just the father Michelle he says
I'll be there for my child but I can't
be with you because you got no respect
you [ __ ] up him in you said you [ __ ]
other men with my kid in your stomach I
said my baby needed dimples huh huh I
kept it funny cuz I take nothing but a
joke because if I take type of the
things that happened to me seriously my
Bobby someone shot chillin and Upstate
in the women's prison I went to prison
once for a probation violation I didn't
even do nothing I didn't commit a crime
I didn't check in with my a B 109s San
Bernardino when I [ __ ] up the Purdue
goes she is pretty little scarred above
my brow he tried to pick up a prostitute
said we were gonna have a threesome was
it asking me was telling me you're gonna
do this which one do you want
it's it ain't happening
pulled his wheels so quick when he
stopped tries to stop for one and I
pulled his car when I got punched in the
face like
my kidneys people's names so they know
we're not telling my story the
[ __ ] are all going to be put on
guard the [ __ ] know I don't
know life and I don't make up stories I
tend not to put the truth and only the
truth cuz I don't gotta make up [ __ ] my
god-given words my god-given word I
don't gotta make up [ __ ] or put extras
on it cuz I tell it like it is
regardless or not I'm telling the truth
you know what you did so not sorry
[ __ ] or should I say mother
lover go [ __ ] your mom Blueface go [ __ ]
your mom shake that ass little baby dad
it's cute right that's what I'm gonna
tell them go [ __ ] your mom when they try
to [ __ ] with me again because where I
[ __ ] up is word I need something like a
place to stay for a night a bowl that I
can't afford and I come begging these
[ __ ] for another chance I give
them the right to [ __ ] me over again you
ever heard the phrase Don don't bite the
hand that feeds you or don't [ __ ] where
you eat and don't rob from your peoples
apparently some people are too high on
drugs and using this excuse you can't be
higher than a kite tell me you don't
know right from wrong
stealing and asking permission is one
thing you want something ask for it you
know heard if they say no but they don't
hurt to ask
I get off better by asking people but I
do have a habit of doing things or
borrowing things without asking and I'll
turn them in last minute they wouldn't
even know the thing was on I both hear
girls report oh boy your flashlight and
this and this he goes when the [ __ ] did
you take this oh the other day when I
was here remember he goes look [ __ ]
you're good I go my bad at least I
brought it back right it would've hurt
you more if I didn't bring it back you
didn't even know what is it was gone so
where's the mister
that part but Ty Cobb one and play and
that was me getting hit in the face with
a dodge I became homeless uh recently
six months ago before my pregnancy
she hit me in the face with a bat and
closed the door had I'm not this big
sights of a golf ball some
indian-looking [ __ ] with a big nose she
had the balls to punch a window in she
wouldn't punch me because she knows she
would have got her eyes to be as small
as I am as pretty as I am I will beat
the dog [ __ ] out of somebody cuz I used
to take kickboxing and I know street
fight
protect kick high knee kick me face
first punch them into stem punch good
that's the weakness they go OOP and that
takes two arrows the bigger they are the
harder they fall hmmm so I don't care
you could be six too and now we'll still
beat you see how quick you four beat
will be because they're men and because
they got muscles that I'm intimidated by
them but I'm not
my name is Ariana Frances Medina 26
years old when I feel like 40 cuz I've
been running the street for seven
humming banging for pies
I had a baking initiation where I had
three gang members from Florence you
[ __ ] me into the hood there's no such
thing as getting [ __ ] in the hood but
I just need to be 550 members involved
attendance was poor only three of them
sold but I [ __ ] them into individuals
in times different times they claimed to
bust the Train on me he did at once I
got respect I did involve until orgy one
time I was smoking the hook I swear to
god they list it was something I would
have did it in some orgy with some vices
in a parking lot my friend my Brody
Brody is another word like a besties but
it's more of a guy in a girl my Brody
used to have a best friend named Lara
Lara
he chose a girl over his best friend
told me to kick rocks because him and
his girlfriend we're gonna make up
threw me out of the trailer like at 3:00
in the morning and HP and um he had a
case of what you call elephantitis 20
her chest is swell up really big it's a
health issue he showed me his balls and
I freaked I didn't want to [ __ ] him I
left him in the moment that night I
walked all night and I've met some guys
in the parking lot smoking a hookah it's
an instant you smoke but I would have
never involved myself or cooperated in a
10-man orgy I called it a dick yester I
made it fun I made it seem like I did
know what I was doing I didn't know what
I was participating and he said if we
grab a box of condoms would you [ __ ] all
of us
I said sure would but that's up after I
hit the hooker so I swear to God so help
me God that I'm lying that they laced it
with something crystal meth maybe it's
crack cocaine possibly then not that
wasn't even on but it doesn't happen is
that been years ago I made a penny a 1 I
started working off Figueroa bigger
always known as the whole stories where
the prostitutes worked they stand in the
corner butt-naked difference between me
and them is her name Stein butt-naked I
earned my [ __ ] I'll stand in booty
shorts chanclas and a little cute health
it tank top once I'm a Wooster
butt-naked by the pommel Crips they
snatched my chin whoa whoa shots fired
I've been holding them for dear life you
can i party so disgusting this
disrespect I can't even hold it it's a
pregnancy and that was the tacos I I
farted sorry he's not a believer dude
okay Mike
we'll talk about yeah let's talk about
whoever does okay back in the music I
got me a company it was crucial it was
like that it's just hit me in the face
like you're pretty good you get all
kinds of breaks cuz you're pretty yeah
pretty nasty one
okay no but I was I mean you're talking
about we can figure out yeah well
getting Figueroa right some guy saw me
he picked me up and said let's make some
money I said what do I gotta do
all you gotta do is say you're you're my
[ __ ] you work for me and you give me
half of your money I sit in the car and
I watch you but see anything sketchy I
got a gun
let me take it from there so I did it
till I met a guy named soldier from
Florence and I left it but once you
leave prostitution you can never leave
it because you'll fall into temptation
and just go back to the money it's so
addicting the money so fast and it comes
and goes so they see a Mexican girl out
there cuz usually seeing nothing but
blacks Chinese white girls it's often
that you see a Mexican girl that there
so today seen a Mexican grow out there
all the other were pulling over you best
believe every five minutes I wouldn't
even walk for three minutes car pulls up
I have white men black men Chinese men
all types men I got a dollar a $50 tip
for letting a black man eat me out [ __ ]
me and have me in a moment for hours I
didn't charge by the time I charge by
the job fifty four head eighty four sex
and 150 for everything talking house
whole and everything included but
I don't let my boyfriend [ __ ] me in yeah
so so or always mandatory but only one
condom because STDs exist and mouth
diseases are disgusting
I only stuck my boyfriend's dicks with
no condoms
but um where I [ __ ] up what nays we're
[ __ ] my ex-boyfriends own best friend
he gave me syphilis thank God it was
curable but those two penicillin shot to
my ass hurt it's a thick white substance
to cure you but where the [ __ ] is is
that I'm not even cured yet I heard even
though I thought those two shots my body
still has to detox from it they said
even though you got those two shots
you're not in the clear yet it's still
in your body you still need a gold
through the subprocesses
take medication or something I found out
yet but I'm not gonna lie I had
unprotected with my enemies and I gave
it to them and I don't regret it
that's a cold piece of work but what's
up but flowers right that's me getting
back at you [ __ ] for your
homies from Watts and I don't care what
what's watts or not West South two
differences what's the tension between
the East and the West apostles talking
about but you like but nothing those
exact words well I love to puck so
ariana are you concerned about the
future of your child yeah you're the
concerned for two things you're homeless
you're living a very rough lifestyle I'm
homeless I'm gang banging and I kick in
with nothing but my enemies I play with
fire all day that's not to be burnt play
with the devil you're gonna get play no
games you're asking the devil if there's
any spirits in the house please make
yourself be known throw something make
touch me make your presence be known I'm
opening the portal to the death death
people are known as spirits because
they're good spirits and ghosts are two
different things demons
are people who can't accept their death
and are lonely zombies just walk around
on earth but unless you say a prayer say
I'm praying for this person sample
Ariana Francis Medina when I die and I
can't accept my death someone's that's
to say a prayer say my name I say please
let this person accept their death and
let them know that they're dead and
they're no longer gonna ever be in a
human body and they're just the spirit
no please let them move on let their
spirit rest in peace and let them know
that they're dead and accept the fact
that your day because some people die so
fast and they're in denial that they're
dead and they're called lonely zombies
walking on the earth those are demons
demons are people who are mad because
they die
they don't want to set their diet people
will get tied up and thrown in ditches
like prostitutes that's where I put
myself what's the most valuable lesson
you've learned all your years on the
street when I had the man sit on my
chest in Fontana what distracted my head
said [ __ ] if you don't suck my dick
I'll kill you I don't know how I got
away but that day I dropped the brick
wall
I'm not spider-man that brick walls I
saw was that gate right there
dig adrenaline made me jump that wall I
was grateful that I got away if you
would have pulled the trigger I trigger
I would have been dead I would have been
telling my story now I wouldn't even
meet it just 26 years old 26 what I live
it's just he's 27 I don't know by the
way things are going people say I'm not
gonna last long yesterday I was yelling
what's up but flowers right you guys
hate me you guys got me bro please
somebody kill me do me the favor cuz I'd
rather be dead and it was life because
life is crucial
I've always been by myself
people don't tolerate me more than a day
or two they get rid of me because I
could be making money but it's damn out
here smoking drugs wasting my life
riding away like a good piece of
forbidden fruit quick joke
my brother my boyfriend's a twin his
twin looks better than him I picked the
wrong one
his friend told me tell John I said his
twin brothers the forbidden fruit Oh God
I said that's where you're right
homegirl I picked the wrong twin his
Funes hair has Keith lives in a house
and a shack somewhere with mother and
eats my baby daddy's an RB slam back on
heroin smoking crystal that [ __ ] are
the [ __ ] and then gets beat like a
dog when I find out cuz you have the
nerve to neglect it in my face but I
found a dick ring and a [ __ ] condom
in his [ __ ] room and he still had the
nerve to deny if that had some [ __ ]
they said oh Jenny I love you Jenny call
their phone I said listen here [ __ ] my
dick he's my baby father if I find out
where you live I will locate you so
[ __ ] quick and put the dog sherry you
leave John alone as my baby's father's
my dick he has a checkmate huh the Nike
sign type to undertake boulders [ __ ]
whoever did that gave [ __ ] huh dag it
because my baby daddy thought he I did I
could sell my pleasure you make more
money than him and make him feel like
he's something right that part my baby
daddy's five four and I beat him already
three times I gave him three little
pretty black eyes he made a joke one
time make the fight that he couldn't
[ __ ] win what a five five and a half
big momma size matters because by an
inch or two I would still be the dog
[ __ ] on you bro sneaky Fernando thought
he was Doug why do I keep ug real I
could jump off the old kid and we're on
that fate cuz you were gonna learn daddy
sir Ariana what would you say to your
family
it's a let's say they watch this video
what would you say I got a little
emotional there because my family on
they barely even let me see them I love
them they still answer my phone calls if
I go to jail they put money on my books
almost if you're watching this
hmm part it's the hormones in the
previous I love you I find anything
forgettable to tell my story so when I
die I'm leaving something behind and
sorry they had to prostitute and
disrespect myself and dad
f sub dad except that I'm in the hood
broth in hey gang banging 421 and I'm
harder than happy these guys they clean
Florence Florence a gang member dad I
got beat up with a crowbar
what's up [ __ ] flowers flower when I'm
dead put my money in the grave
I love you dad mom you never were in my
life
you lied to me said you were recovered
at it to get me to get on a bus and meet
you at Las Vegas Nevada [ __ ] you mom but
I love you I say it out of love but
you're you're a cold [ __ ] for that I
hate both of my parents because they
just had me throw me on the world and
said you're on your own daughter my
brothers the sisters weren't DCFS I'm
not even good pursue lucky for them
because I don't know where to go
I just know three of my brothers two of
my half-brothers from same dad different
mom my dad cheated on his girlfriend it
had me that's a pretty story that's how
it was me cheating scandal I didn't ask
to be born but I'm here now and I'm
living to the fullest and one day my
story will inspire other girls I know
life is hard but there are no such
things making it out of the rock bottom
you fall down you pick yourself but
you're a lady don't take men for granted
don't don't take money don't do drugs
because drugs are very bad and they're
addicting as much as I would have known
that I was adult baby and as soon as I
hit that drug that first time I was
gonna get highly addicted I would have
never picked it up but one time I was
smoking weed and my homeboy from
Florence yeah yeah there goes my I'm
homeboy right pass me the pipe is say
here on where he wanted this
I said what is it he said it's called
crystal man it's called the G pipe dope
I hate it one time and I got addicted I
couldn't let it go
every time I see someone hitting it I
start shaking
it's called feeling for it my body says
get it get it get a pick it up I begged
for drugs I sell my ass for drugs and I
deal with dumb asses and put my hands in
the enemy's mouth jumping a shark tank
expecting to have a hand left when the
sharks chew me up but like I said my
family I don't blame them for giving up
on me there's so many times I said I'm
going to rehab but it's easy saying it
but it's not easy doing it but the
streets are my motivation I say in the
streets because it's my daily program
it's like me living in the pen
I'm institutionalized if I get out there
you ever seen that movie where that
black guy hangs himself because he was
institutionalized and once they let him
go
he was free he the knowledge of how to
develop himself
sittel with society so he hang himself
that's me if I leave the streets and I
go in the house and I pretend to be
normal
I'll kill myself I can't my knife will
never be normal gangbanging drugs a
prostitution is what I learned and
that's my story
and cut
you